hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play to Neverest Lake oK we've
just got through this door this part
took longer than I thought it would but
it still scared the bejesus out of me
man I tell you the maker of this mod is
an evil genius his pacing is perfect and
now the main thing didn't quite make
sense but yeah since I played an ax I
know to put everything to everything and
that is the room of nightmares
[Applause]
Oh
now Gus so much oil I know what to do
with it they're just feeding you more
and more
[Music]
ja another spider at the in it whatever
you can even kill you
ah I've been testing paintings old-time
haha okay all right okay
I just books oil oil potion it spoil my
favorite should be a lot of useless runs
you think that would catch fire
why is it so dark
oh ah there you are douchebags later not
like it actually could kill me or
anything okay the heads I tossed I
thought it was like a secret secret
fully blockages or an employer but that
is that is haha
I'm a genius pulley was that the only
one now [ __ ] you fighter
haha but what did it do
[ __ ] you spider actually that really
hurt why are these chairs in here
I've been in here wait where's that door
that was blowing off your hinges tonight
oh yeah I've been in here okay good did
I get anything I didn't get anything
what's the point of being down here I
pulled it I pulled it sure
okay pulled this did the blue glowy
thingy I think I can leave now was there
nothing else in here we just double
checked I didn't really get a good look
okay all right headed back up and got so
much practically shooting out my box I
like this they didn't open the Nathan's
made weird sounds oh maybe
[Music]
looks clear I was gonna meander along
just looking at that give me the willies
oh oh oh no [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
oh [ __ ] up okay I don't know what the
deal is okay I don't see anything it's
got to be in here it's not that door
then it was something else in this room
that I must have missed there with me
guys
they're with me and thinking with my
thinking brain when there is nothing
left of God there was nothing else in
here there was nothing else over here I
pulled up a book I didn't see any other
closed doors these are still locked
what is the deal I can really looking
now really look super search mode
checking every room again find their
skulls back place in a big circle again
this is still locked
oh maybe hang on wait a tick wait a tick
am i that stupid
I might just be
Kurt chunk and then no don't
I hope I didn't like bug the game or
something it was only gonna work once I
don't see any other books like this okay
looking for ones that look just like
this yeah I'm not seeing I get you
spider hold you to book move it here no
here
damnit what your frickin Frick is going
on please tell me it's not bugged all
the way up oh [ __ ] off you spider [ __ ]
anything here no just destroy Cheers
mmm alright maybe that door wasn't it
but damn it i hope i didn't [ __ ] things
up I hope I did Oh what about in here
duh this is a freaking library
[Music]
nothing come on gimme some gimme some
babe come on babies double check oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah still looking for books
but I don't need to look that hard cuz
probably not what I need oh just frickin
maze then give me ten bucks in a while
oh hey chapter but I have failed you
recently found out what's going on here
and decided to drink one of these
potions in order to forget all horrible
things he's done for my research okay
but he didn't count on losing the memory
of his wife and children so I removed
them from their cabin at the lake so
Edward won't be suspicious I could
always use another test shop Jr tooth
wait a minute what
okay so that's not the main Bob oh no oh
no another worms oh no oh no okay so
that's not the main character that I'm
playing
so this oh there I think the voice by
the same guy so that's why I see damn I
lost my lantern I need to find a new
[Music]
being Asian without a man awaiting call
a whale mating call a male waiting never
mind
[Music]
hello
now before I go in here ah there's a
safe spot here
I'll hit I only got a minute left on
this part yeah that's right okay now I
need to find a lantern the Turner's he's
feeling of watcher I can read the name
of the broken pipe it says x-14 see what
weird name for a pipe
I call it Jerry Jerry's stop leaking all
over yourself Jerry stop being an
embarrassment to your family
Jerry stop beating you I think it's just
disgusting
anyway thank you so much everybody for
watching that's all the time I got for
this episode so thank al see you in the
next part
bye
[Music]